la française des jeux sur pas privatiser
l'état gardera une part de kate avant la
fin de l'année dans cette affaire je
sais pas qui joue mais on commence à
voir tu tousses renoncer à ces
privatisations
[Musique]
la française des jeux
la fdj c'est la société qui possède le
monopole sur les jeux de loterie en
france elle détient aussi plusieurs jeux
de paris en ligne
elle est l'héritière de la loterie
nationale créée en 1933 pour venir en
aide aux gueules cassées les victimes de
la première guerre mondiale
une partie des revenus leur est reversée
encore aujourd'hui avec l'essor des
médias et surtout de la télévision les
loteries deviennent très suivie elle
rapporte beaucoup l'état décide donc en
1989 d'augmenter ses parts dans la fdj
l'état contrôle avec des gis à hauteur
de 72% avec d'autres actionnaires
minoritaire en 2017 avec la loi pacte le
gouvernement annonce la privatisation de
la fdj
il a annoncé qu'il voulait céder 50% du
capital lors de l'introduction en bourse
de la france est mieux l'état privatise
la fdj parce qu'ils estiment aujourd'hui
que c'est plus une participation
prioritaire et stratégique pour lui et
surtout c'est l'occasion de récolter de
l'argent il en attend plus d'un milliard
d'euros nous avec le présent la
république avec le premier ministre nous
faisons ce choix d'un état stratège qui
place l'argent des français dans
l'investissement et de l'innovation
les partisans expliquent et s'était
inscrit dans la loi pâques que c'est
l'occasion de financer un énorme fonds
dame d'innovation qui pèse 10 milliards
d'euros
c'est aussi l'occasion de
d'accélérer le désendettement de la
france à 1 et contribuant avec cette
privatisation ainsi que celles
d'aéroports de paris
l'état se heurte à une forte opposition
en privatisant la fdj l'état perdrait
une entreprise qui rapporte beaucoup
la française des jeux c'est des recettes
fiscales très importante à l'année pour
l'état 3 milliards 5 et ses recettes
resteront même si et ça c'est un
argument des opposants l'état en se
désengageant en grande partie de la
française des jeux va réduire fatalement
tous ses dividendes
l'état va donc perdre entre 100 et 150
millions d'euros chaque année sur le
revenu de ses actions mais il espère en
embaucher un milliard sur leurs ventes
les opposants redoutent également la
perte du monopole de l'état sur un
secteur des jeux de hasard sensible les
opposants disent attention
est ce qu'il faudrait pas mieux l'état
qui contrôle
on redoute surtout que des investisseurs
privés qui prennent le pouvoir sur des
jeux d'argent est des intérêts qu'ils
soient pas forcément les meilleurs parce
que quand on dit jeux d'argent on pense
blanchiment on pense addiction enfin jeu
des mineurs
la privatisation de la fdj est donc un
pari pour l'état mais qu'en est il pour
les joueurs auront-ils plus de chances
de gagner
commercialement parlant c'est à dire
pour les joueurs pas d'énormes
changements
la française des jeux créés tribu les
joueurs avec eux des taux qui sont fixés
d'avancé et a priori elle sera tout
autant généreuse c'est vraiment une
entreprise qui va bien un business
modèle qui fonctionne un modèle qui
attire chaque année plus de 25 millions
de joueurs en france avec la
privatisation ils auront une autre
solution pour s'enrichir acheter les
actions de la fdj
c'est une privatisation qui est ouverte
à tout le monde
en premier lieu bien sûr aux
particuliers aux investisseurs
particuliers puis le but c'est de faire
une opération privatisation assez
populaire c'est de reprendre un petit
peu les grandes privatisations qu'on
avait
dans les années 90 et 2000 ensuite ça va
permettre surtout aux français de
pouvoir investir dans la française des
jeux
parce que moi je souhaite que la
française des jeux redeviennent
l'entreprise des français alors faut-il
acheter les actions de la fdj
et est-ce un investissement fiable pour
les particuliers la française des jeux
c'est une société qui est solide
financièrement qui est en croissance sur
les 25 dernières années
le chiffre d'affaires a progressé de 5%
par an c'est énorme c'est une
progression régulière ça plaît beaucoup
aux marchés c'est le genre de société
qui n'est pas impacté par tout le
problème dont parle actuellement
ralentissement de la croissance mondiale
etc
c'est une société sûre et solide et ça
devrait normalement évidemment plaire au
bout particulier en plus pour inciter
les français à investir dans les actions
de la fdj
l'état a mis en place des conditions
favorables pour les acquéreurs pour
réussir l'opération il ya plusieurs
décisions qui ont été prises la première
c'est qu'il ya un petit bonus
les investisseurs particuliers dans la
tranche 6h sa réserve et auront
un discours de 2 % sur le prix de vente
et puis surtout ce qui est très
incitatif c'est pour ne pas qu'ils aient
de spéculation à court terme
tous les particuliers qui ont participé
à la privatisation et qui garderont
leurs actions pendant 18 mois auront une
action gratuite pour dix ans c'est quand
même une belle
c'est une belle incitation à la fois à y
aller et également à garder des titres
pendant un certain temps pour ne pas
tomber dans le bief évidemment de la
spéculation à court terme et
d'opportunisme avec ces conditions
favorables les actions de la fdj suscite
de l'intérêt notamment chez les
investisseurs étrangers
c'est par exemple le cas du géant du jeu
de hasard tchèque sarka pour éviter un
rachat massif d'actions par ce genre de
groupe l'état a imposé quelques règles
aux investisseurs il ya une petite
précaution qui a été prise par les
pouvoirs publics l'état pourra donner
son agrément ou en tout cas refusé un
actionnaire qui voudra prendre plus de
10% pour les futurs investisseurs il
faut rester très prudent
par le passé les privatisations ne leur
ont pas toujours réussi il a eu de très
bonnes opérations tf1 ça s'est très très
bien passé les banques ça s'est très
bien passé
en revanche il ya de très mauvais
souvenirs il ya tu as qui s'est pas très
bien passé france télécom il ya eu cette
montée en flèche de l'action dans les
années 2000 et ensuite j'ai eu un trac
et les gens n'ont pas toujours n'ont pas
encore retrouvé leur mise
dans ce qu on a privatisé il ya une
vingtaine trentaine d'années il y avait
beaucoup de sociétés assez risqué assez
cyclique mais là on commence par la
française de jeux on limite le risque
était qu'une bonne opération financière
banco
[Musique]